якщо ви дійсно хочете дізнатися про
війну про те Хто вбиває і катує хто
віддає накази і яка зброя
використовується то інформацію про
багато що з цього можна знайти в
інтернеті Еліот хіггінс британський
засновник беллінг Кет шукає ці на
оброблені дані і викриває жорстоких і
впливових людей в Україні його команда
вивчає докази воєнних злочинів Росії але
також вивчає дії заходу в інших країнах
ми писали Про авіаудари з США в Сирії в
результаті яких Загинули мирні жителі ми
писали про Афганістан та інші теми коли
учасниками подій були США та інші
західні держави Але Росія робить багато
справді поганих
речейнс не соромиться називати імена але
він змагається на полі інформаційної
битви де факти якими б докладними вони
не були регулярно оскаржуються і
відкидаються як фейк News чи стала
правда знеціненою валютою
[музика]
Ласкаво просимо в конфлікт зон Дякую що
запросили мене у передачу називаючи
імена вбивць переслідуючи воєнних
злочинців ви вразили деяких надзвичайно
сильних світу цього в їхні болючі місця
чи переймаєтеся ви тим що вони можуть
становити небезпеку для вас
це те що постійно турбує і мене І
беллінкет як організацію справді
починаючи з 2015 року ми піддавалися
різним нападкам Спочатку це були
кампанії з дезінформації у російських
ЗМІ потім кібератаке які постійно
супроводжували нас у повсякденному житті
у беллінкет і звичайно зараз коли ми
дедалі більше вивчаємо поведінку
російських спецслужб ми дедалі частіше
стикаємося з проблемами безпеки про які
нам доводиться непокоїтися
липні Генеральна прокуратура РФ включила
вас до списку небажаних організацій які
становлять за їхніми словами загрозу
конституційному ладу та безпеці Росії Чи
поставилися ви до як попередження що ви
безумовно зачепили їх За живе чи ви
радше розглядаєте це як почесний знак
Насправді те і інше насправді турбує те
що нас переводять із розряду просто
порушників спокою в очах Російської
Федерації до розряду організацій Збільш
серйозним статусом коли нас фактично
зараховують до терористичних організацій
тому що це має величезний вплив не лише
на нас а й на тих людей які працюють із
нами та підтримують нас Отже знаєте за
ці роки з боку Росії справді
спостерігалася ескалація щодо белінкет
починаючи з компанії дезінформації та
закінчуючи оголошеннями нас небажаними
інформаційне поле Як таке стало досить
неприємне місцем не в останню чергу в
судах чи не так один із найближчих
соратників Путіна Євген пригожин подав
на вас до суду за наклеп через
твердження що він є босом пвк Вагнер але
позов був відкликаний ви однак пішли
проти його британських адвокатів і
подали до них скаргу до регулю органів
Великобританії заявивши що їхні дії були
можливо зловживанням судового процесу
чому
у Великій Британії у нас багато проблем
зі справами типу Sleep так що слайд - це
стратегічні судові позови проти участі
громадськості так так от Це був дуже
яскравий приклад такого позову тепер ми
знаємо що пригожин визнав що весь цей
час стояв за вагнером він ніби зірвав із
себе маску він приховував своє обличчя
весь цей час але ви знаєте що ми дійсно
знали про це всі ці судові справи Це
нападки на його критиків насправді
Давайте поговоримо про Україну з вашого
дозволу у вас вже деякий час є офіс у
газі і Ви допомагаєте міжнародному
кримінальному суду проливати світло на
воєнні злочини та тих хто їх скоєє як
просувається ця робота в Україні в
Україні Ми зараз використовуємо метод
який ми спочатку розробили вивчаючи
авіаудари Саудівської Аравії в Ємені для
розслідування військових інцидентів
використанням даних із відкритих джерел
коли я почав займатися цією роботою коли
я заснував беллінке я пропускав що цим
займатимуться інші люди що вони
розберуться у процесах але насправді ми
виявили що ми керуємо цими процесами Так
ми працювали з міжнародними юристами та
іншими організаціями над розробкою
справді надійного процесу розслідування
і насправді це означає що ми можемо
створювати досьє які можемо передавати в
різні органи я хотів би поговорити про
один конкретний випадок у квітні ви
вивчали повідомлення про масові
порушення прав людини у місті Буча під
Києвом коли воно перебувало під
російською окупацією росіяни заявили що
ваші твердження були хибними вони завжди
так кажуть але наскільки ви були здатні
відповісти на їхню зустрічну критику Ну
мені здається що російська дезінформація
навколо таких інцидентів як обуче була
справді досить жалюгідною лише Минулого
тижня в облікових записах соціальних
мереж російських посольств публікувалося
відео Ну ви знаєте з спростуваннями і
одне з цих спростувань було фактично
засноване на словах випадкового
французького хлопця який зробив дуже
перебільшені заяви стверджуючи що він
був там і бачив як батальйон АЗОВ
складав тіла над землю і що інші
журналісти спостерігали за цим що є
абсолютною нісанітницею ми маємо знімки
з безпілотника супутниковий знімки та
інші джерела зроблені до того як
Українські війська увійшли до міста які
показують що ті ж тіла лежали на місці
за кілька тижнів до їхнього переходу І
звісно тепер ми маємо результати роботи
багатьох організацій які були на місці
та розмовляли зі свідками вони змогли
перевірити чому ці тіла там з'явилися
йдеться простирати російськими
військовими ви знаєте що є навіть один
чоловік з групи людей яких відвели а
потім усіх розстріляли а він вдав
мертвого і він єдиний вижив він також є
дуже важливим свідком є записи камер
відеоспостереження на яких видно як цих
чоловіків виводять також фотографії
трупів цих чоловіків і з того місця де
їх застрелили Таким чином доказів
справді величезна кількість тому я думаю
що в усіх останніх конфліктах сучасності
в яких ми хочемо притягнення до
відповідальності за такі злочини Україна
справді є найкращою Надією не здійснена
цього якщо цього не станеться ми дійсно
маємо подивитися на те наскільки добре
працюють наші методи із притягнення до
відповідальності тому що це справді
найкраще з можливих обставин для того
щоб це сталося
що стосується притягнення до
відповідальності Якою мірою можна було
співставити окремі Злочини з людьми які
їх вчинили
це складна робота Але на щастя оскільки
рівень безпеки даних російських операцій
дуже-дуже слабкий вони використовують
відкриті лінії зв'язку вони ви зламали
їхні засоби комунікації Вам не потрібно
їх зламувати вони використовують
незахищений радіозв'язок ще до початку
конфлікту наприклад ви могли зайти на
сайт де люди організову прямій
трансляції російських радіопереговорів і
вимогли чути як вони перемовляються крім
того український уряд та спецслужби
України ведуть масовий запис усіх
можливих перехоплених дзвінків які вони
лише можуть знайти і ви бачите що багато
що з цих розмов публікується В них
російські солдати розмовляють Зі своїми
сім'ями тощо я думаю що існує така
величезна кількість доказів що справа
вже не у відсутності доказів це питання
можливості зібрати воєдинок справи та
судові переслідування на основі тієї
величезної кількості доказів які є на
даний момент у серпні ви розповіли про
свої спроби вистежити вбивць які по
нібичили та стратили українського
полоненого ви почали з трьох жахливих
відео з російського телеграм-каналу а
закінчили реальним номером телефону
підозрюваного який говорив із вами
знаючи що ви журналісти але Він
заперечував основні звинувачення Як ви
думаєте ви знайшли правильну людину
думаю так коли ви робите таку роботу є
альтернативні сценарії які можна
розглядати наприклад добре а якщо це не
так чим здається за яких обставин Це
може статися і з огляду на інформацію
яка у нас є ми знали де вони були у нас
була та сама людина на іншому відео в
тому ж місці ми бачили що він одягнений
у той самий одяг на відео були ті ж
транспортні засоби які було видно на
інших відео де він фігурував дуже важко
уявити будь-який інший сценарій для
цього потрібно було б хтось інший
продягся у всі його речі одягнув ті ж
самі прикраси та інші деталі та видавав
себе за нього для створення цього відео
а також співпрацював із росіянами для
цього часто в такій роботі ви дивитеся
на відсотку ви ймовірність того що може
бути правдою і в якийсь момент
ймовірність будь-якого іншого сценарію
стає мінімальною крім тих сценаріїв які
ми досліджували
Звідки у вас виникла мотивація займатися
такою роботою ви мали офісну роботу в
місті Лестер ви багато грали у
комп'ютерні ігри як у вас виникла
мотивація яка призвела до створення
белінг Кет та намагання притягти
злочинців до відповідальності за скоєні
ними злочини Як ви прийшли до цього
Це відбувалося доволі поступово коли я
почав цим займатися я справді був просто
знаєте людиною яка проводить багато часу
у форумах у мене був інтерес до політики
та подій навколо арабської весни я був
значною мірою частиною онлайн-культури в
якій ви сперечаєтеся з людьми в
інтернеті Про те і про це мене трохи
засмучувало висвітлення подій у ліві
коли основні газети писали Про те що
відбувається грунтуючись на даних своїх
репортерів при цьому був величезний
обсяг інформації яка надходила з джерел
на місцях люди знімали те що відбувалося
ділилися цим у соціальних мережах та на
інших платформах і ця інформація
здебільшого ігнорувалася єдиними хто
сприймав її всерйоз були прихильники
теорії змови які використовували її як
доказ на підтримку своєї теорії про
причетність црум або щось таке але я
зрозумів що я щось Що можна зробити що
дає набагато глибше розуміння та
детальніше уявлення про конфлікт ставало
дедалі очевиднішим що я знаходжу те що
ніхто інший не знаходить і я думаю що це
справді сталося у 2013 році коли я ви це
знайшли тому що вони не шукали Я думаю
частково справа була в тому що вони не
знали як перевіряти контент із
соціальних мереж у минулому було кілька
скандалів наприклад у 2012 році був
блогер під ніком едеї Girl interestos
який широко цитувався у багатьох
західних змін Згодом він виявився білим
хлопцем з Америки який просто видавав
себе за іншу людину Я думаю що для
багатьох Це була конфузна ситуація і
через це соціальна мережам стали менше
довіряти але я розробив методи перевірки
таких речей як місце де щось було знято
із часом я створював все більше і більше
методик використовуючи досвід інших
людей поки ми не змогли створити майже
повний набір методик розслідування які
дозволяли отримувати докази на дуже
високому рівні перевірки Я думаю що
ситуація кардинально змінилася коли ми
розпочали розслідування того що сталося
зі меч 17 на сході України малазійський
авіалайнер який був збитий у 2014 році
правильно тому що біля анкет була
заснована незадовго до того як був
збитий і меч 17 усього за три дні до
того це було за три дні до трагедії так
сам Цей факт запустив кілька теорій з
мови чому ми раптом запустилися і так
зацікавилися цим до речі про цій теорії
змови Чи є у Вас якісь зв'язки із
західними спецслужбами як дехто
стверджує про вас є багато людей які
вважають що ми регулярно спілкуємося з
ЦРУ британськими спецслужбами мі-5 мі-6
та іншими або що ми фінансуємося ними
навіть росіяни висували такі
звинувачення і не таке відчуття що вони
щиро вірять у це зараз але це неправда і
ми робимо багато круків щоб бути
прозорими щодо наших джерел і доказів ми
прозорі щодо нашого фінансування ми
існуємо на пожертвування тому ми
проходимо незалежний аудит тому ми
намагаємося бути максимально прозорими
але завжди знайдуться люди які вірять у
теорію змови такою є природа інтернету
під час кількох розслідувань ви і наші
партнери виявили низку вбивць найнятих
Російської держави ви відслідковували
їхні пересування їхні телефонні дзвінки
їхнє місце проживання реєстрацію їхніх
автомобілів їхні внутрішні документи
навіть номери на їхніх квитках можна
зупиністю сказати що ніхто з цих людей
швидше за все не постане перед судом за
вчинене тож на що можна сподіватися
раніше ми говорили про відповідальність
ви хочете позбавити їх бізнесу
застерегти інших людей від подібних дій
думаю звичайно ми вже бачили що наші
матеріали ускладнюють діяльність деяких
російських шпигунів
це Одна справа яку Ми займалися та
нещодавно опублікували про жінку на ім'я
Марія Делла яка була світською левицею у
Неаполя вона мала свій бутік Вона часто
ходила на вечірки і була членом
благодійної організації lions Club
створеною військовими місцевою бази НАТО
виявилося що насправді вона була
російською шпигункою ми виявили що
росіяни використали послідовні номери
паспортів для підроблення посвідчення
особи своїх шпигунів і вона була в одній
із цих послідовностей номерів на той час
ми про це не знали Хіба це не халатно з
їхнього боку ну Річ у тому що довгий час
це сходило їм з рук тож навіщо їм було
змінювати методи роботи і ми з'ясували
це лише тому що Росія корумпована з гори
донизу більшість нашої роботи з викриття
шпигунів заснована на використання даних
які ми отримуємо на ринках даних у Росії
у Росії всі на всіх рівнях влади тією чи
іншою мірою займаються шпигунством і
багато даних продаються публічно на
громад будинках це має бути незаконно
але нікого це не хвилює тому що вас
ніколи не спіймають і ви можете заробити
тижневу зарплату на одній угоді ми
купували такі речі як записи телефонних
розмов записи польотів квитки паспортні
дані дуже докладну інформацію Справа в
тому що Росія - це фактично поліцейська
держава вони збирають величезну
кількість інформації про своїх громадян
навіть про своїх власних шпигунів тому
ми змогли отримати записи телефонних
розмов які дозволили нам встановити не
тільки те кому Вони дзвонили але їхнє
пересування Ми використовували це у
розслідуванні справи скрипаля отруєння
навального та у багатьох інших справах
це в певному сенсі було величезним
приниженням Російської держави чи не так
тому що ви ідентифікуєте людей яких вони
використовують для вбивства політичних
опонентів ви не знаєте як це сприйняли
російські служби безпеки як вони
відреагували на ваші викриття Полювання
на відьом чи звільнення як вони
відреагували
що стосується конкретних людей у
багатьох випадках їх перевели на
кабінетну роботу розумієте вони більше
не можуть працювати в польових умовах
мова не лише про шпигунів про яких ми
публікуємо розслідування а й про тих хто
з ними пов'язаний на даний момент вони
не знають що ми знаємо про їхніх
шпигунів вони також на мою думку
переконані що ми є частиною спецслужб
тому що в Росії дивлячись на захід якби
така організація як белянкет і існувала
Вона точно була б пов'язана із
спецслужбами Я переконаний що вони
абсолютно переконані що ми працюємо на
спецслужби але поки що у них немає
ефективної протидії тому що ми робимо
тому що більшість нашої роботи з
виявлення шпигунів заснована на тому що
вся російська система корумпована і що
ми можемо отримати доступ до даних які
недоступні в інших країнах
ми трохи поговорили що ви готові робити
ви купуєте інформацію на Я вважаю це
можна назвати чорним ринком в інтернеті
це даркнет чи не так ви проводите
онлайн-розслідування Чи є хтось щодо
кого ви не проводитимете розслідування Я
маю на увазі наприклад британські чи
американські війська звинувачувалися у
скоєнні воєнних злочинів в Афганістані
ви б стали це розслідувати так безумовно
нас більше цікавлять питання
відповідальності тому ми не
займатимемося знаменитостями і тим чим
вони займаються бо це просто Бульварна
нісенітниця але якщо є воєнний злочин
якесь порушення то це те що ми
розглядатимемо і хоча я думаю що у нас
репутація видання яке приділяє багато
уваги Росії ми писали і про авіадари США
у Сирії наслідок яких Загинули мирні
жителі ми писали про Афганістан та інші
теми коли учасниками подій були США та
інші західні держави але просто Росія
робить багато справді поганих речей Тому
нам є про що писати крім того у них дуже
погано з інформа важливою безпекою Тому
це відкриває широкі можливості для
розслідувань в Росії Еліт хіггінс ми
могли продовжувати нашу розмову з
чудового Дуже дякую за участь у програмі
конфлікзон дякую
[музика]